noella i cannot think of another
housewife who stepped into her first
season and so
much
happened so
fast we are
we're only a few weeks into your debut
season but it feels like we're deep into
it what's it been like watching your
life back in this way
very surreal
[Laughter]
this is definitely not what i thought i
was signing up for if i if i had any
inclination this would be it i never
would have done this um so in many ways
ignorance is bliss i never thought that
this would be
the end of our marriage you know i never
thought that that would mean
that i'm a single mom with our
son i just want my husband back i want
him to come and
tell me what the hell is going on and i
commend you for bearing it all um i
think to the surprise of many of your
co-stars how much you've bared so
quickly
but we will unpack all that i want to
rewind because much has been made about
how you made your way on to the show and
into this group and so i want to set the
record straight on what that process was
like because thank you you say that
you're i'm gonna call him your estranged
husband so your estranged husband has
claimed that you were obsessed with
getting on the show that this was like
all you cared about
you have said that he's the person who
pushed you to do the show so
where's the truth live um so the the
truth is vicky gumbelson who was a
housewife at that time did insurance for
my husband's life insurance and somebody
from cassio had reached out to me for
the show
and
i squealed and said to my mom and it was
amazing and told my husband and he would
talk to vicki about it so this was
something that he was very aware of we
did our due diligence we do other
couples we were good friends with braun
and sean
um he knew what this whole experience
was we would discuss like ways that this
would benefit his brand his business his
office i had no desire to create some
business to plug on the show the irony
is i actually the first time i spoke
with heather and terry uh privately i
said we were gonna steal your blueprint
and that was the plan up into the day he
took his toothbrush and left the house
and still to this day hasn't told me why
he left or
you know what what happened to the plan
got it well that makes sense too because
i think there have been
the doubters were like well it looks
like she
inserted herself into vicky's inner
circle and when that didn't work out she
was in bronwyn's inner circle but it
sounds like these conversations have
been happening for a while now anybody
who lives in orange county knows this is
a very very very small town
you're kind of gonna like you just go
out to mastros i mean i'm gonna be the
masters tonight
any future wannabe housewives just just
pop into uh sebastian's if you want to
send me an espresso martini i'll i'll
put you in for gaston
you were friendly friends almost
attached to the hip judging by social
media with bronwyn
it seems like it was a
fast and furious friendship that did not
last can you shed any light on
what happened there
um i vood we we yeah i mean how do i say
this it's because i'm hoping that the
friendship isn't completely gone so i
don't even want to put out there to the
universe on what the demise for that
time was
um but it timed out
when i
found out that i was going to get this
opportunity
it was that same time that i i had some
trust issues with bronwyn
and it's really just between us i know
um so i've not given up on it i'm hoping
that there will be a day that we can
reconnect it's just right now timing is
everything so
yeah no that makes sense and i can read
between the lines there what was your
relationship with the show before you
were on it were you a fan because i've
heard people speculate that you were a
super fan and that you know all the ins
and outs of all these women's lives but
what was your relationship how would you
describe it i i i think it's like the
the kiss of death to admit this but i
mean i'm all honesty all the time so why
stop now of course i watch every single
episode of every single season of almost
every single franchise i love bravo i
love the show
i'm not ashamed to admit that i don't
understand why that's a
a bad thing to admit
uh but i also am a human being who's
able to like meet people and get to know
them
and so that's why i can easily say that
i'm shocked that shannon and i
you know bonded so quickly but every
single woman that i met every single
conversation that i had all the
relationships that were forged they were
sincere
and i think that that you can see that
and really was coming from my heart and
really is genuine i think the thing that
is maybe shocking people are making
people
wonder is you go
to deep conversation
immediately which is not the norm for
most people so i think that's maybe the
the piece of the puzzle that people are
like well
is it genuine or is she performing
because even like tamara judge and
brandi glanville said on tamara's
podcast they think you're making scenes
and performing for the cameras and like
delivering a performance i just feel
like it's just too much too soon
honestly i mean i i think she's
beautiful and everything but stunning we
just started the season and she's
already like breaking down in a
restaurant yeah
and refusing to get out of the
restaurant and making a scene i'm like
it just seems phony well it's a lot it's
a lot to bring out she wanted she wanted
to get on the show for a very long time
what do you say to that
really breaks my heart because i love
brandy i think that she would she and i
would have like
probably some good sex but
[Applause]
but at least a really fun time so that
really sucks that somebody i've never
met you know as is out there saying
stuff that's not true and
i mean one more ex-housewife who's
clapping on to the newbie to try and
have you say their name it's kind of sad
and now i've learned that if i ever have
a podcast because one day my day will
come that i will not be asked to come
back on this and if i have a podcast
after that i have failed in life
i just had the worst week of my life i
just reached out to you to ask if you
need a girl
not being rude to you we can't do this
at two parties
let's unpack your and jen
dr jen getting off on
a weird foot
because it seemed to as an outsider
looking in that she was being genuine
wanting to pull you aside have a
conversation be like check in on you
and you shut it down so what happened
there was there something more to the
story with jen there there was something
for the story no i did not get furiously
upset with her because she tagged me to
post it's weird it's definitely weird
but it's not like end of the world
scorched earth kind of stuff but no
there was some others
there was something that she did to hurt
me and potentially my family
a year ago before we were at emily's
house that lovely evening and i said it
to her face and
because it is so fourth wall it it just
didn't we didn't discuss it but i think
it's relevant and i think can you i i
mean can you give a little hint i
understand if you can't give it all away
but what could somebody do to damage and
hurt your family she put words in my
mouth that i never said
okay noelle is lashing out and bullying
other women i don't think there's ever
an excuse to be rude and condescending
and mean to somebody else
jen makes a comment that you are
bullying the other women what do you say
to that
says the kettle i mean
she's she's the bully she gets all of
the women over to her house to speak
really horrible
lies about me well i'm in fact going
through this crazy painful
traumatizing time with my very young
family
so the fact that she just sits around
collects information
to use against me and then tries to get
a cabal of women together who i've took
meeting these are new relationships
you know and so she's actually
technically known me the longest here
she is like spreading just lies that she
knows are lies for the sake of hearing
her own voice
i think that's more bullying than
than anything that i ever gave to her i
mean all i told her was that she was a
rude little girl and in that moment she
was a rude little girl
this fourth wall thing that you bring up
do you plan to address that at reunion
if it doesn't come to light before
that's what units are for because i
think inquiry reminds you to know it's
just it's she has a bit of a track
record uh with me
and with with some others but you'll see
of taking something that has like a
little greater truth to it and twisting
it into something else in order for her
to talk
and for people to listen
and i find that to be artificial drama i
find that to be manufactured and i kind
of don't have time for that it just it
sucked that
she she really wanted to have a
conversation
when
all the ladies were around
she you're you're implying that she
instead of being real and taking time to
contact you in the moment she was saving
it
to have a moment and be in front of the
cameras
you said it i did it okay yes of course
obviously yeah that's that's exactly
what i'm saying
all right well to move off of jen to the
other person
who i don't think
has become your friend
heather de bro
you two
never seemed to figure out how to walk
in line together
um
why do you think
that is why do you think you got off on
the wrong foot and seemingly stayed on
the wrong foot i love the way you asked
that or just stated that because you're
you're correct we never could walk
together because she insists on walking
ahead of everybody she doesn't want to
walk together she doesn't want to hold
hands
this doesn't feel as if we're
friends
in a friend group that are kumbaya it
feels more like there's queen heather
we're in the court
and
quite honestly initially i was down for
that i was cool with that because i was
like oh my gosh like i'm geeking out
like i love heather so i was all about
that and then you know
things happen you're gonna have to watch
you are a liar and a thirsty girl and
i'm done
kind of shocking you understand what
thirsty means
let's start with the fake [ __ ] comment
nicole told me that you called me up
either a phony [ __ ] or a fake [ __ ]
heather will be supportive
what the does that like fake [ __ ] i
have to say right now what we never
really get
the reason why you feel that way there's
this conversation about you feel like
she
muzzled
nicole from talking about the lawsuit
drama beyond that first party is that
the only reason you call her a fake
[ __ ] or is there more to that because
you do kind of walk back calling her
that but it seems that you
but it seems that you believe it seems
you still believe her to be one though
you see me like dude i was tap dancing
on ice for that you see that like i try
so hard to just make peace like i really
just i didn't want to talk about it i
felt it and i it wasn't really i felt
even my place to bring stuff up i didn't
like it i was observing it i was telling
gina just heads up i think this person's
more interested in recruiting soldiers
and genuine friendships just just be
wary i'm trying to give heads up to
people
um that i i knew could potentially get
hurt but at the same time not divulge
heather's
secrets because you know it really it
wasn't my place this is all born out of
you feeling like she was trying to
silence nicole is there more
no i know she did okay no of course
there's more something shady happened in
her subterranean and it's
it is disgust amongst the ladies and
it is something that was a pretty crazy
story that was confirmed by various
people
and
did you have this information you're
talking about at the time you called her
a fake [ __ ] or is this come to light
later and had it then
everything happened
at her party
so crazy things happen at the party and
then nicole leaves and then i'm on the
phone with nicole
and i find out a lot that night
just realizing piecing things together
and seeing
how
she's just
a big [ __ ]
okay i mean it's you're trading barbs
back and forth you call her a narcissist
in the episode she calls you psycho
vibes
um
i'm so grateful that she called me
psycho vibes because i really did feel a
little badly about calling her a
narcissist so i'm really happy that
she's also going dirty so that way i
don't feel like i can sleep well at
night so it's like okay yeah i'm evenly
matched
you make this comment of shoving people
into walls the start of our friendship
was in your house with you slamming
people against walls and yelling at
people and then we were slamming people
against walls i heard it i was right
near the staircase but there was it was
it was slamming against walls
and i feel like if there was footage of
this they would show it so we haven't
seen this moment
or maybe
they're waiting for her to just
be honest
i mean something that would be very
smart would just be like you know what
i was protecting my my husband my brand
my business and frankly it's nobody's
business and maybe i blacked out and
crossed the line but keep my name out of
your mouth that i can respect i would
have been very happy with
let's never talk about this topic again
it's none of your business
but the fact that she's calling me
psychotic and a liar and apparently i
need to go home and take care of my
children and my mental emotional
well-being because i'm you know unless i
view her as perfect i can't be friends
with these women
i
it has to come out now
when you said on watch evans live that
nicole's voice was taken from her are
you referring to
heather silencing her and telling her
not to say anything yes heather
okay
uh what was your relationship with
nicole like before the show we knew each
other for years we were like super close
super crazy clubs so and then of course
leading up to this experience we were
speaking every single day for hours
hours
so i mean and then all of a sudden that
stops i knew when something was off um
and it just it was painful to watch it
was just painful to see that like
something in her like her a light had
dimmed into her because she felt torn
you know between her own
voice and between a voice that was being
whispered in her ear
we know that nicole
walked away from this group at some
point i think it's sooner rather than
later in the timeline of where we are in
the episodes what was your reaction when
she decided to distance herself because
you come into this thinking i have a
buddy who i get to experience this with
and i have a built-in support system
who's then gone
yeah well when the built-in support
system turns on you you're kind of okay
with their departure
at some point she kind of crossed over
to the dark side so i was okay with that
um but just it was kind of very
serendipitous like one week like after
filming that we just bumped into each
other at mastros just coincidentally and
we just instantly it was just like
taking the show out of the equation kind
of then fixed the
rip that had happened there well i think
her treatment by the person who is in
her ear and seeing that that was the
actual fake friendship and see that that
was the manipulation that that was the
thing that was actually toxic and her
being able to see that for herself
that i think that that that was it
because i've never been anything but a
great friend to her for years she got a
lot of flack for how she treated you at
what i would call the tears on my tits
lunch
um
come on i'm having a break time right
now i'm feeling living
i don't feel comfortable my life is
falling bar
you chalked that up on watch fabin's
live to
the heather of it all and heather being
in her ear but it also seems that what
we saw in the episode was
condensed that you were there for much
longer than we saw so these moments of
her looking cold-hearted
i don't think were an accurate
representation of maybe what happened
that day
i mean really what we see is a
girlfriend being embarrassed that her
girlfriend's drunken in public and
wanting to get me into a car and get me
home safe that's really it i see what
the viewers do see but there is um
there's there's no malice
but um but yeah it's it's beautiful to
have her back in my life and to see that
she's found that voice
and you know she's she's back my baby's
back
this all leads up to you getting iced
out of the first group trip
to mexico
how did that make you feel to know that
everybody was invited by you
so the crazy thing is like i i'm the one
with the plane
i actually have a legitimate gulf stream
i mean i'm won't after this divorce but
so that was kind of weird where it's
like wait a minute
i'm the one who does these kind of
things and i'm the one who you know
um god it sounds so stop me but facts
so yeah no it was it was very weird but
i understood why i mean i was in that
podcast room you were there too like we
all saw it like i completely understand
why
um
you know i would be disinvited by our
hostess uh but
yeah it's the cabo gets very complex
yeah because you
while you're not there at the start you
show up at some point so how does that
work that you
wind up there see that one yeah that's
that's it all it's all there but you're
gonna have to stay tuned for that do you
stand by going and i was invited and i
thought that it would at that point be
rude and i was hopeful that this was a
good step in the right direction
oh was i wrong but
is this where the you gave my daughter
pornography conversation happens yes i
didn't want to invite you because you
gave my daughter pornography as a gift
you're you're going to want to watch
that one that's confusing did you
give max pornography
uh yeah that's totally that's that's
what i do on on my off days i go by
children pornography no shock shockingly
heather used her words incorrectly and
she
put out a very salacious and somewhat
criminal allegation
because she kind of needed to get up
something more salacious and chevy
people against walls
okay
you